es ist kurz nach halb sieben als der
mann in den stadtbezirken wilmersdorf
schöneberg und tempelhof sechs menschen
durch unfälle verletzt drei von ihnen
schwer
am innsbrucker platz raste er mit einem
schwarzen opel astra an einen
motorroller im bereich detmolder straße
überfuhr er ist einen und in höhe
alboinstraße dann zwei weiterer
motorradfahrer unfallverursacher kam mit
seinem fahrzeug unmittelbar danach zu
stehen und verließ sein fahrzeug stellte
dann eine munitionskiste auf das
fahrzeug oder und behauptete dass es
sich um einen gefährlichen gegenstand
handeln würde
die kolleginnen und kollegen die zum
einsatzort geeilt sind haben ihnen
unmittelbar festnehmen können und
anschließend die kriminaltechnik
entsprechend analysiert nach seiner
festnahme wurde der mann in eine
gefangenensammelstelle am tempelhofer
damm gebracht und die autobahn
sicherheitshalber weiträumig gesperrt
sprengstoffexperten des lka untersucht
das auto des irakers und die darauf
stehen der kiste unsere kriminaltechnik
hat den verdächtigen gegenstand waren
hier am ort durchleuchtet und hat dabei
festgestellt dass ich eigentlich nur
werkzeug darin dass heute aufgrund der
gesamtsituation
sind sie aber auf nummer sicher gegangen
und haben ihn mit einer wasserkanone
aufgeschossen was letzten endes dazu
führte dass es sich bestätigt hatte fand
sich lediglich werkzeug in diesem
der staatsschutz hat mittlerweile die
ermittlungen übernommen er überprüft ob
der iraker der psychisch auffällig
gelobt haben soll einen islamistischen
hintergrund hat mir jetzt zugeschaltet
mein kollege peter wilke peter werden
gerade gehört mehrere menschen wurden
schwer verletzt gibt es schon einen
neuen kenntnisstand dazu wie es den
opfern geht
ja insgesamt wurden sechs menschen
verletzt drei von ihnen schwer
einer von ihnen soll ein feuerwehrmann
gewesen sein der offen nachhauseweg war
er wurde noch in der nacht notoperiert
erlitt schwere kopfverletzungen
außerdem wurde wurden ein opfer das
schon am münsterplatz ein motorrad
roller fahrer der angefahren wurde
er musste noch an an dem ort nach
unseren informationen reanimiert werden
wir sehen gerade hinter dir dass die
spurensicherung noch immer läuft was
genau passiert da gerade ja genau wir
können das hinter mir sehen einmal da
hinten sehen wir es ist jetzt verdeckt
von einem polizeiauto den unfallwagen wo
an der fahrzeugfront noch das motorrad
zu sehen ist in das er zuletzt hinein
gerast ist die polizei ist sie immer
noch seid jetzt über zwölf stunden vor
ort sichert spuren wir können das auch
sehen dort hinten werden mit mit gelber
kreide die fazit wer weg den das
fahrzeugen über sich fuhr auf der straße
gekennzeichnet die polizei sicherheit
halte eben die spuren jetzt gleich soll
auch eine drohne oder eine drohne ist
auch hier bereits schon gestiegen um die
das ganze die ganze szenerie von oben zu
sichern und ein luftbild zu bringen und
das ist halt alles im endeffekt
hilfreich um das tatgeschehen hier
nachvollziehen zu können
bereits gehört der amokfahrer wurde
festgenommen was ist über ihn bereits
bekannt ja es soll sich um einen 30
jährigen iraker handeln und wie die dpa
aus ermittlerkreisen jetzt erfuhr soll
er wirklich aus politischer motivation
gehandelt haben das möchte die general
generalstaatsanwältin auch heute
nachmittag einem dem rechtsausschuss
mitteilen und ja deswegen ist stadt
weiter abzuwarten was dann noch mehr
über seine motivation bekannt wird aber
es scheint sich immer mehr abzubilden
was hier schon zu vermuten war weil er
ja auch allahu akhbar geschrieben haben
soll eine munitionskiste auf das auto
gestellt hat und gesagt hat wenn ihr
näher kommt werdet ihr alle sterben dass
es sich um eine politische motivation
handelt mutmaßlich um eine religiöse
oder islamistische motivation
das ist auch der grund warum der
startschuss jetzt in diesem fall
ermittelt ja genau aus diesem grund
ermittelt jetzt auch der staatsschutz